في أعقاب 7 أكتوبر،
لم يكن لدى الإسرائيليين استراتيجية جيدة، ليس الأمر
كما لو أن هناك صيغة سحرية
لم يروها وكان ينبغي أن نخبرهم
ما هي الصيغة السحرية الصحيحة
وهذا غير صحيح، فقد كانوا
عالقين إلى حد ما بين  IR Roa ومكان صعب
فيما يتعلق بما يجب فعله، أعتقد أنك تعلم أن
حدوث حالة من الهياج وتعلم أن قتل
أعداد كبيرة من المدنيين ليس أمرًا
خاطئًا من الناحية الأخلاقية ولكنه أيضًا
ليس في مصلحتهم الإستراتيجية، صحيح أعني لأنه كذلك
لن
نشتري لهم أي شيء بشكل صحيح، وفي الواقع
سيكلفهم ذلك الكثير لأن
الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم ينقلبون
ضد إسرائيل أه، رأيت أنك تعرف
مركز أبحاث إسرائيليًا اليوم آه كان
يتتبع الاحتجاجات في جميع أنحاء
العالم، وقد أعطيت بعض الأرقام  لما
بدا أه بين 7 أكتوبر و
13 أكتوبر من حيث عدد
أه الاحتجاجات حول العالم كانت
مؤيدة لإسرائيل مقابل مؤيدة لفلسطين ثم
نظرت إلى الأرقام من ش
13 أكتوبر حتى الوقت الحاضر وأعتقد ال
كانت الأرقام 69% مؤيدة للفلسطينيين في
الأيام الستة الأولى بعد 7 أكتوبر.
69% وأعتقد أن 31% يأخذون هذه الأرقام
على محمل الجد. 31% كانوا مؤيدين لإسرائيل
لذلك أعتقد أنهم كانوا 69 و31 منذ ذلك الحين
منذ 13 أكتوبر إذا  أنظر إلى
عدد الاحتجاجات حول العالم، 95% منها
كانت مؤيدة للفلسطينيين و5%
مؤيدة لإسرائيل، وما يخبرك به هذا
هو أن الرأي العام في جميع أنحاء العالم
قد تحول ضد
إسرائيل.